and human beings our principal made in
the image of that logo and that's why we
can see things in to be it and you and
when you see truth then you see paradise
into being and when you see fall clean
detail and view and that's the truth and
what that means is that with every
decision that you make you decide for
yourself and for everyone else whether
you're going to tilt the world a little
bit more toward tell or a little bit
more towards heaven and that's the
burden you bear for your existence and
the choices that you make as you test
for life and it's the fleeing from that
it's at the bottom of the nihilism of
post-modernism and the escape into the
totalitarian certainties of idol worship
and none of this is fictional because
we've seen the consequences Jonathan
said quoting I don't remember the source
that there could be no poetry after
Ashley but that's wrong but the poetry
has to be about Auschwitz the lessons
from arsenic was never again and paradox
but you you can't decide not to repeat
something terrible unless you understand
it and the way to understand it is that
it small things at each individual
culminate in the great students of the
state and since when you ask why careful
things out in the world the answer is
quite simple the answer is because
you're not good enough and it's because
you don't tell the truth and you know it
Jonathan says something I thought was
very interesting it's something I
thought about but I haven't taught them
about it at all
what happens as you move towards the
truth and answer is everything comes
together it reading separately is the
answers everything comes together is
even a sexual element to that because of
course the highest element of sexual
ecstasy is to come together and around
someone who's telling the truth
everything comes together and that's the
potential destiny of the world it's
something that you can partake in it's
the call it's the call to the greatest
adventure that there is you can bring
forth something again to paradise by
seeking the truth and you can start in
your own life and you can started in the
life of your own family for these are
people in principle that you love until
why would you do anything to speak the
truth to them to protect them from
reality
there's no protecting anyone from
reality reality disk is you interact
with it on your two honest terms can you
do that by facing it forthrightly and
you do that by not shying away from the
challenge I spend a lot of time trying
to understand the Sermon on the Mount
it's a very strange document I'm going
to tell you what I think it means it
means conceptualize the highest your
diction count and so you might think
that would be the highest good for you
and it would be the highest good for the
family around you that you love
including the highest with that family
in the state and it would be the highest
rate for the state in the world and that
would be the highest possible would aim
at that even though you don't know how
aim is that make that what you want and
then tell the truth and it's an
adventure because you don't know what's
going to happen you have no idea because
it increases instrumentally retreats
people instrumentally use them as tools
for your own desire and that's the
problem with that is what do you know
about what you desire many things that
you chase will turn out to be empty well
what happens if you just tell the truth
well the world will unfold around you in
very strange into serious ways and there
isn't anything that's more exciting than
that
perhaps something exciting enough so
that suffering that the tendons on being
would redeem itself by God adventures
and that's the call that the Western
calls in the individual the suffering of
being can redeem itself through truth
and it's not it's not a rule it's not a
proposition that you need to adhere to
like a good citizen it's it's the proper
way of mending your way through the
terrible world without making it worse
than it already is it's a possibility
perhaps of making it better there's no
more exciting possibilities than that
and no higher moral demand because the
thing is is everyone knows that you know
when you lie according to your own
conception of the truth that there's
something something shameful and
demeaning about that and you know that
it hurts people and you think well why
do you do it despite all that and partly
to do it because it's easy and partly
you do it because there's a crooked
horrible hellish part of the soul that's
more than happy as part of what you do
is make everything worse to pay for the
sin of its existence